on a l'impression que au fur à mesure
qu'on avance dans le temps perd la
mémoire la mémoire de la collecte la
grande peste de la peste noire est resté
très vivace en europe
il en parle tout le monde sait les
enfants aujourd'hui savais qu'il y avait
la peste en europe au moyen âge on a
tous beaucoup moins de souvenirs de la
de l'épidémie de grippe espagnole au
lendemain de la première guerre mondiale
qui m'a pas tant de faire des dizaines
de milliers au nord ça c'est loupé pts
et oublier en partie et plus récemment
la grippe de hong kong en 1969 qui fait
quarante mille morts en france un
million de morts en europe
on l'a complètement oublié comment
est-ce que vous expliquer qu'on oublie
si vite ce qui s'est passé récemment
et alors qu'on garde en mémoire ce qui
s'est passé il ya longtemps je n'ai pas
d'explications précises mais ce qui est
certain c'est que le l'ampleur de la
contamination le nombre de morts est
extraordinaire la déflation
démographique qui accompagnait cette
grande peste est également les
conséquences économiques et effroyable
le désordre social penser aux litiges au
procès pensez également dans le domaine
de l'éducation la sueur maudit de la
surmortalité des clercs donc les enfants
n'avaient plus en classe
il ya vraiment attachés à cette image de
la peste médiévale une imaginaire
extrêmement violent extrêmement brutal
qui peut expliquer que l'on ait gardé en
mémoire cet événement et lily a aussi
les illustrations il ya des peintures il
ya tous les témoignages une livre est
picturaux qui sont là pour nous le
rappeler
ce qui est aussi très étonnant et là bon
c'est bon on déplace on se déplace un
peu c'est
les parallélismes qu'on peut établir
entre ce qui s'est passé en 14ème et
15ème siècle et ce qui se passe
maintenant il y a comment dirais-je il
ya plusieurs choses qui me frappe
il a d'abord ses peurs et ses peurs
irrationnelles
ça c'est un premier point
le deuxième c'est le les croyances les
croyances qui se multiplient et les
fausses rumeurs des fausses croyances la
violence également les effets de cette
de cette contamination je pense en
particulier au massacre des juifs ou aux
flagellant bon ce sont des images est
extrêmement forte
l'image du bouc émissaire est également
la faillite de l'état et de l'église
d'une certaine manière
[Musique]